[Music]
okay everybody i'm so excited today
because i am joined by brenna diameko
aka april in night night which is out
tomorrow on demand brenna how are you
doing today
i am doing so good and also you said my
last name right
i love it
um i'm so excited i think everybody's
really gonna enjoy this film
oh i'll tell you i i loved it i got the
privilege of watching a little early um
i'm excited people to see you in this
now
you're playing this very serious role
now you're the lead of this film
approaching it as an actress
when is the moment you feel confident
how you're approaching the character of
april you play like you feel like okay i
got this down like in your prep when do
you hit that port yeah that's a great
question um before um night night i only
worked on certain projects that weren't
very drama heavy um the only one that i
did before that was when i was about 17
playing a pregnant teenager on code
black as a guest star
and as soon as i got a little taste of
that i always knew i wanted to do drama
um i just i felt it like drama is more
my niche dramas i love everything i love
the light hard work i love comedy as
well i just think drama really excites
me so when i read that script of night
night i was like
it's a psychological thriller like i
want to do it so badly so the
preparation was a little different from
preparing for somebody um
uh for a networker for a character
that's comedy i i i just needed to build
a relationship with her and know why she
thought the things she did and why she
did the things she did in order to pull
it off
yeah and you totally do pull it off and
it's good because you show that you you
have that connection with april which it
shows you put in that work on screen now
speaking of your work on screen there's
a lot of time that you're by yourself in
certain scenes a lot of solo scenes can
you kind of as an actress maybe give me
maybe like the pros or cons if you want
of doing scenes without other scene
partners like is that more frightening
um i think
um that's a really great question i
never feel alone in a scene not because
of um you know crew camera director or
whoever being around because i kind of
have learned to
shield that out just for the
authenticity of the scene and feeling
more in it but i'm never alone i never
truly feel alone because i always have
like my thoughts going um so i
i think it's more overstimulating for me
to be in a scene alone than with another
person um with my other co-stars because
my brain is running a mile a minute
especially as april and so many of these
scenes she's
like
she's not even speaking so it's all in
here it's all right here so i think
those were maybe a little more
overwhelming yeah than being with
another person instead so i could just
like talk it out it was all internalized
and i think that's why she struggled so
much with
knowing if it was in real life or just
in her head
yeah and that's what's interesting too
is like the audience throughout this
film is going to feel like trying to
figure out what's really happening and
there's a lot of twists in the film too
so
as the actress of april
to get to that point of her character in
certain moments where you've read the
script ahead but do you have to kind of
play dumb a little bit in your head to
kind of forget what you already might
know is coming to really gain the
character is that maybe too extreme
absolutely i think um i think i've grown
to
kind of build this little mental switch
um where i can go method for a scene but
not completely you know for days months
on end just for maybe an hour or so just
to protect my mental as an actor um but
there was one time
uh when we were filming for about like
six hours the same scene that was a very
very very intense scene i don't want to
give too much away um but it was a very
very intense scene and i kind of like
lost myself in it for a couple hours i
didn't mind it because i knew it was
happening but it was overwhelming in
like the coolest way
but yeah yeah you have to kind of block
yourself out of it and leave all the
moments for a minute
sure so
like leaving all those moments for a
minute are you someone
after you do any work you do as an
actress are you excited to go watch
yourself or you're someone who's like
i'm not watching my performance or you
like grab some popcorn and watch how do
you do it
i i'm excited to watch like for the up
for my other cast mates and for
everybody yeah that's done it like i get
very nervous watching myself for sure
because i'm so over critical of myself
all the time
um but this one i was really excited i
was like really eager to watch this one
because it's just so different like i
said from what i've done before and i
was so excited to see everybody and how
they reacted and um and nikki and ryan
were saying how much they loved it and
then when we saw we were all like that
was sick
yeah oh yeah and yeah your fans are
gonna love it and i think it's exciting
to see you like you're saying doing
something a little different
now does it stop there with like
thrilling horror are you open to like
all genres are you someone's like i
won't do that or so open open yeah
absolutely i think dramas
just i love it so much i was fortunate
enough to do other two other horror
shorts during the summer this past
summer um and i loved doing them so i
think horror is something i definitely
want to keep building on my resume and
thriller and you know psychological
thrillers like this because i love them
yeah and i i think they don't ever get
old people want more and more of it so
it's smart that you're doing this uh
switching gears a bit having been a
younger actress in a huge disney
franchise and descendants is there
anything you learn from that time that
you bring to your work you do now like
oh absolutely thank goodness i had
parents um
that were so supportive and believed in
me so much but also made sure i stayed
humble through
you know thick and thin because it's
super exciting when you're 13 and you
get to be on a set and you know people
are offering to put your shoes on for
you and holding your straw um and the
first time it happened i was like mom
like mama like that's crazy she goes
yeah honey that's great but i want you
to try everything in your power to make
everybody's days a little easier because
everybody's trying to get through the
same day and everybody is just as
stressed as everybody and i and from
that point on like i immediately
just did every little thing to try to
make everybody's jobs a little easier
which and
fortunately brought back them being
happier and you know the happier the set
the easier it's going to flow so i try
to do that in every set i i'm on
oh that's great and yeah it seems like
you you're smart about it you're
learning and you're already such a pro
at a young age which is awesome thank
you
and it's exciting to see where that will
go next um but in that time even during
the days of descendants or now even is
there a current actress or actor you
look up to or someone you looked up to
growing up is there anyone that kind of
inspires you there was so many i looked
up to growing up and still do but right
now
i'm obsessed with florence peel
oh my god okay i'm sorry i have to draw
because i have asked this question a
couple times it is always florence pew i
mean i
wow that's amazing that's amazing people
love her
she is just
insane and amazing and just
does a little bit of everything and i i
just watch her interviews constantly i
watch her constantly i also love
victoria padre
her last name is from you
um and honey of hill house i'm obsessed
with her as well i think there's they're
so stylized in how they approach every
character and they're so them but so not
and i love it i love it
those are those are two great picks um
and yeah there's a lot of stuff you do
you have so many hats and i think it's
really fun on your instagram you do
different uh musical covers and you most
recently did a cover of billy eilish
happier than ever which was great but
what's really cool about it is that
you're also a skilled musician because
you're playing piano and some you're
playing guitar and others uh is music
the first love for you growing up is
there an equalness to maybe acting in
music do you not compare them
i try not to compare them um
but i i did start music
before i started like musical theater at
eight years old when i did just because
my dad was suzuki trained all by ear
when he was growing up and um so i
played piano for a really long time then
did guitar um but i love it and i'm
coming out with some music soon and i'm
really excited for people to hear that
yeah hell yeah and it's great too
because you also have just a great
social media presence in general and i'm
to ask you some advice is that
you i think if correct me from wrong
used to post videos on youtube and
they're not there anymore and now you're
posted on tick tock is tick tock where
it's at now am i doing this wrong is
youtube the old man's game like where
where is the where is it to be is tick
tock it no i think it's wherever
wherever your audience and wherever your
platform suits you best i think it's
it's assessing the algorithm and and
doing your research and educating
yourself on exactly what works for you
and your platform and your niches i love
tik tok because i just feel like i can
be so silly and myself and also i do
have an older fan base on tick tock and
a little bit of a younger
fan base on instagram but i just love
being super silly and also doing
relatable things make people feel less
alone and can give them a laugh or two
in a little bit and you know a couple
seconds but yeah i just i do try to use
my platform
um just for good and and supporting
charities that i really love and
foundations and quotes and letting
people know that being human is being
human and you know you'll get through it
and we all go through hard times and
just just letting people know that just
because somebody has so many followers
somebody does so much it doesn't mean
nobody's better than you everybody's
trying to get through the same day and
just to let them know they're not alone
yeah that's that's great uh advice here
um my last question for you before i let
you go because it'd be disservice to all
your fans if i don't ask you this but
people love you as jane and the
descendants right so would you want to
see a descendants four happen and are
you up for it if it does come about
i don't believe a descendant's four is
going to be happening um but i'm so
happy with all of the movies that we've
done um and i think descendants 3 is my
favorite one and i know a lot of them
say the same
and the music is so good and my favorite
song is by far nightfalls break this
down love them
oh amazing so everyone here all the
brenna heads out there you can watch
brenna now crush it in night night it's
out tomorrow on demand brenna thank you
so much for joining me today and i hope
to talk to you again in the future thank
you so so much